- Alright so we pan across a
park, beautiful park, peaceful.
We see a old man sitting
at a bench feeding ducks.
He look like Grady
from Sanford and Son.
Is he still alive?
Nevermind, we'll let casting
worry about that, anyway
he's feeding the
ducks, all of a sudden,
the ducks start exploding.
(duck noise) Pop! (duck noise)
Pop, pop! (duck noise) Pop!
The old man look at the camera,
he's been feeding them seltzer
tablets the whole time.
He said, "I told these
goddamn ducks a million times
"to stop shittin' on my car.
"I set a trap in my house,
they come to my job.
"I call the police,
they say I'm crazy.
"It's called animal control,
they don't control shit.
"I got they ass
now doh, ha ha ha."
Let out a evil ass laugh, right,
then the old man die of
natural causes right there,
bam, on the ground, a bunch of
blew up ducks and a old man.
Kai-rom, turtle wash car wax.
'Cause you ain't got
time that for that shit.